e
e e
call the meeting to order of the joint
performance audit and oversight
committee we do have Quorum and um so
the first order of business is the
minutes of August
27th I move to accept the minutes of
August
22 thank
you good afternoon we are just taking up
the minutes of August
27th and
um do they need any changes or
Corrections that anybody noticed
if not then um if you're in favor of
adopting the minutes as presented please
say I I any
opposed
perfect next um we're going to get uh
updates on the status of ongoing
performance Audits and Christine is
here and I do not that representative
ative Smith has asked to speak on the
first
one good afternoon Madam chair and
committee members for the record my name
is Christine Young director of audits
for the LBA and with me is Jay Henry
performance audit supervisor so I'll
start with an update on the audit of the
New Hampshire commission for human
rights uh that is the audit that is the
furthest along in the process at this
point uh the EXE itive director of the
commission continues to be out on leave
and the assistant executive director no
longer works for the
commission the commission voted to
appoint an investigator as the acting
executive
director since the last LPA meeting
we've had discussions about our draft
report with the commission's legal
councel at the Department of Justice uh
legal councel has been working with the
commission of uh human rights uh with
the Commissioners on that commission um
to discuss the
report on November 18th we received
written feedback on the report from
those Commissioners uh the report's been
revised in response to the comments and
a revised draft report was sent to the
commission on November
26th final audity responses are due from
the commission on December 20th and uh
we are expecting to have an an exit
meeting in
January a presentation of the report to
the fiscal Committee in February is
hopeful are there any questions from
Miss Young or Mr
Henry thank you
um I'd like to invite representative
margerie Smith to the table and just
interrupt the flow of this event
welcome thank you very much um Madam
chair um and I have to begin by being
quite honest about the fact that I have
a bias my bias is that I think that the
office of the LBA is the Crown
Jewel in
uh when we look at all of those people
who assist the legislature in doing its
work mostly we think of the LBA in terms
of budget but we also have to think
about the LBA in terms of financial
auditing and performance auditing I
happen to think that
although I'm sorry to say that most
legislators do not know or pay any
attention to the work of the performance
audits they are the most
important uh operation that we have in
terms of us being able to
know what we as the legislature have
done well and not done well in
creating uh all kinds of entities in the
government and also how those entities
are performing it is now going to be
three terms ago that questions arose
about the work of the Human Rights
Commission they were not following the
rules they were not following the law it
was documented again and again and
again and we came the Judiciary
Committee asked for an audit it took up
quite a while for that to get started it
was delayed again and again and again
because the head was not able to do the
work that was
required um now today uh I I've just
heard for the first time that there are
actual
dates my and if for finishing the
process if those dates are are in fact
honored it it's a long time coming and I
would be really delighted but I would
like to say to those of you who are on
the committee now and who may or may not
be on the committee um in the new uh
legislative term but who will certainly
have records to pass on that if they
continues to be the
delay um that we have experienced month
after month after month something has to
be done to stop that delay and to tell
the human rights committee that it is
time to follow the law um I I know that
sounds
harsh uh and it is harsh but it's harsh
because um there are people out there
literally whose lives depend upon the
work of the human Rights Commission I of
course am not privy nor should I be
privy to any of the findings of the of
the uh the LBA performance staff but I
would be very surprised if they did not
find that I'm correct in the statements
that I made about the unconscionable
delays that have gone on and
whether subsequent action is taken by
this body or another body um this to me
represents uh the nadier the worst of
what has happened in state government in
terms of our paying attention to what we
do it's all well and good for us to
create a body to solve the problems of
the citizens of the state but if we
don't pay attention to whether that is
what's happening then I think we are
found wanting and Madam chair I thank
you very much for letting me um vent my
spleen in this but I do think that it is
of concern and should be of concern to
every
legislator thank you thank you for that
input any questions
for representative
Smith no thank you thank you very much
for coming in
we'll see you
tomorrow Madam chair I would have a
question of LBA regarding that issue oh
okay come on
back so just curious about sort of the
protocol because it sounds like the
delay really is because there was
inconsistency with the executive
director on leave so I'm wondering if
there was any less Lessons Learned or
any protocol sort of developed for um
making sure that we're still able to do
what we need to do uh and you are able
to do what you to do when there is a
shift in leadership like
that thank you um this is definitely an
unusual situation um usually if the head
of a department leaves then you have the
next person uh on the list that will
move up and uh will be able to deal with
the audit but um in this case um we had
the um assistant executive director also
um not available uh left the commission
so then um the attorney at the
Department of Justice had to step in and
uh sort of take over and start helping
out with the audit um the Human Rights
Commission is administratively attached
to the Department of Justice so um you
know we're lucky in that sense that
there was somebody there that that could
uh help us out with the audit and help
us try to finish it up but um this is
not a typical situation um so we're kind
of in uncharted waters here and just
doing the best that we can to to work
with the attorney at the Department of
Justice to to um you know help us with
finishing up the report and get the
audity responses so that we can get this
thing um released
any further questions on this audit well
we'll look forward to
February yes hope
so okay shall I move on to the state
oversight of special
education um the audit is currently
staffed with four Auditors uh field work
is expected to conclude this month we
continue to draft observations for the
uh completed portions of our work and as
I reported the last time that we met uh
five observations have already been sent
to the department and we have another
five observations that are in the final
stages of the review process and those
should be delivered to the department
this
month more observations are expected to
be delivered in January and a full draft
report is expected to be completed in
mid 2025
is this the H you told us would have 40
or 50 observations and be like yes the
collected works of Charles thingss yes
this one will be a lengthy
report so um last last meeting I think
you
said early spring of
2025 now I'm hearing mid mid 2025 yeah
what what is the reason for and it's
just you know delays include um you know
it's a very broad audit scope that we've
explained before the the the topic
matter is complex um we've had many um
requests for information that we've sent
out and there is a massive volume of
data that um we are looking at to
complete the audit um we've had to have
several follow-ups on our requests for
information we're continuing to work
with the Department and um they're
providing us the information that we
need um so it's takes a long time um
they have another person that is out on
leave currently so we're not sure how
that will impact our timeline but we're
hoping that it's not not going to impact
it too much because we are expecting to
finish up fieldwork this month and then
it's the observation writing process
that we will continue to do and it
will'll be Magnum this
questions thank
you okay I'll move on to the education
Freedom account
program the audit is currently staffed
with three Auditors uh the team finished
its risk assessment and uh they're
finalizing their audit plan now uh field
work is starting and um we uh were
informed that the education Freedom
account administrator is resigning from
his position there and uh his last day
was November
25th um he was the one staff member that
was responsible for oversight of the
contractor the children's scholarship
fund uh so it's unclear how this vacancy
will affect the audit um we're not sure
how it will impact the audit
timeline um and if you recall in our
scope statement we anticipated
presenting our audit report to the
fiscal committee sometime in the spring
of
2025 uh we're still hopeful for that but
we'll see based on the the new vacancy
that we have there now so do we know
who's going to take the place of that
individual in terms of this audit I
don't think there's a replacement yet we
haven't been uh informed of a
replacement there
okay
questions
okay okay so we'll move on to the
doorway
program we had an entrance conference
with the Department of Health and Human
Services on September 12th since then
the team has uh met with the doorway
staff and they're receiving documents
that they've requested for the audit uh
We've drafted the scope
statement and uh John clinch senior
performance audit manager is available
to present the scope statement now um
for your consideration and approval if
you'd like to hear from him Madam chair
yes I I have a couple of questions about
the
scope and probably other people do too
good afternoon for the record my name is
John clinch I'm a senior audit manager
with the office of legislated budget
assistant uh I come before you today to
present the audit scope for the doorway
program um the doorway program was
established in January
2019 by governor and Council to develop
Implement and operationalize a Statewide
network of regional hubs for opioid use
disorder treatment and Recovery Service
is the doorway program's purpose is to
function as a single point of
entry uh into the system to help those
with the op opioid use disorder and
other substance use
disorders each doorway is contracted by
the DHHS to provide treatment support
and resources for prevention and
awareness um on page one of the scope
statement that I believe you have in
front of you uh we talk about the core
services are outlined
there um on figure one on page two shows
doorway program staff consisted of six
positions an executive program manager
two program Specialists a business
systems analyst a business administrator
and a vacant internal auditor
position uh figure two on page three
shows there are nine doorways uh located
across the state in Berlin conquer do ke
Lebanon Littleton Manchester and
NASA table one on page
four shows revenues and expenditures for
State fiscal years 22 and 24 the doorway
program is funded completely by federal
funds total revenues and expenditures
for State fiscal years 2022 through 2024
were approximately $76 million in total
on page five table two shows some of the
program metrics tracked by the program
for State fiscal years 22 and
23 in September also on page five we
talk about a earlier program evaluation
in September 2023 the Pacific Health
policy group was contracted to conduct a
program evaluation of the doorway
program using data primarily from
calendar year
2022 the report recommended improvements
in the area system areas areas of system
Care Quality monitoring and financing
and
sustainability um we will Design the
audit to answer the following question
did the division of Behavioral Health
effectively monitor the provision of the
doorway program during State fisol years
2022 through
2024 our objectives will be to determine
the number of citizens directly
participating in the program determine
how long it takes for them to access
services and evaluate the division's
contract management and monitoring
functions as they pertain to the doorway
program we anticipate the pro uh
completing the audit and presenting to
the final the final report to the fiscal
committee and calendar year
2025 I'd be happy to take any questions
you may have resentative
Weber thank you so much for all of that
it's good to see you again um I was just
curious looking at the program metrics
that you were looking at and also
somewhat the recommendations of the
earlier program
evaluation is there anything that tells
us anything about the outcomes for
people that use the program I mean I I
see that we're doing a lot of
things uh the question I would have and
I'm not sure how you would evaluate it
but if there was any way of telling I
would love to know is is this making a
difference is this I mean it's $76
million and are
[Music]
people I mean you know there's stuff
about wait times to access service but
are people actually getting the services
they need and is it helping in their
recovery is really
what the nub would be for
me uh thank you for the question
um it's a difficult area to assess the
outcomes
um it's something we hope we can get to
uh but I'm not sure that there's going
to be data for it uh we're going to do
as much as we can to come up with those
outcomes um my understanding is the
department now has um surveys that
they're using for determining outcomes
uh but we haven't seen them so I can't
really speak to um what they say or
anything like that Jennifer Saven from
the um department is
here and perhaps can elucidate on your
question if you yeah um there are no
other seats at the table so Mr clinch
will just oh there is one actually okay
there is
20 yeah come on over
next thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Jennifer Sabin I work at the Department
of Health and Human Services and the
division for Behavioral Health and I
oversee the state's opioid response um
so in the previous evaluation there was
a small cohort of could you speak more
in directly sure there was a small
outcomes cohort of Medicaid
beneficiaries um that was evaluated
small meaning a 200 so when you're
looking at the bigger numbers of
everyone impacted um but to John's Point
who is moving through the system who's
accessing care and what their outcomes
are is hard to determine however with
that small group of people we were able
to answer your question which is a
question I ask a lot which is is anybody
better off right it's great that we
served a lot of people but are their
lives better are they going on to get
well um and the answer to that was yes
so in that small cohort we could see um
symptom ology related to people's
substance use disorder at intake then we
could see Medicaid claims where they're
receiving treatment and then at their
six-month followup they're reporting
reduced symptomology related to their
substance use disorder as well as other
benefits around their relationships
their employment and their housing
status Senator with sure thank you madam
chair this is similar to representative
Weber's question but I'm curious did the
department initiate the uh evaluation
from Pacific Health policy group and
what has been the progress made on the
development of this monitoring and
performance Improvement frame sure yeah
we did pursue the evaluation because the
doorways were new right so anytime
you're building new infrastructure after
a certain period of time in this case
was about 5 years to do a look back and
see how things were going um it was an
idea that was modeled off of a number of
other states but whether or not things
that work in other states work in New
Hampshire is always a question for us so
we did pursue that evaluation in
dependently um and then we recently um
provided an update to the governor's
office which we provided to John and his
team about progress to date I don't
think we have that today but we can
provide it for the
committee representative
wer thank you madam chair so along with
the U results I would wonder the relapse
rate and some people coming back sure
they so sober for a while then they're
back then they're sober for a while on
their back and I would think you would
have the name from previously so you
could say person is had four or five
relapses obviously that would say the
program wasn't working as intended sure
although I would argue that substance
use disorder is a chronic health
condition that is relapsing in nature
like diabetes and hypertension and so um
needing to access care throughout your
life is not uncommon and does not mean
that the person is failing or that the
treatment is failing um there are
certainly times where we're able to
connect people's records however there's
a lot of um security and privacy
particularly around substance use
disorder records from the federal level
with 42 CFR part two so for instance um
I live in summersworth so if I accessed
care from the Wentworth Douglas doorway
in Dover and didn't have a good
experience for some reason I could
present at the doorway in lonia and not
tell them that I was seen at a mass gen
hospital and those wouldn't necessarily
get connected because my records are
kept private and so we do our best to do
d d duplicate the number served um but
really we do have a come to the doorway
early come to the doorway often
perspective and so um not limiting when
people are accessing Services the number
of times and how often is important to
us it seems like we're allowing the
Privacy to to interfere with really
making the program effective and we
ought to be able to do something about
that if they just repeatedly go to
different places and there's nine
different places they could go they're
they're hiding their relapse rate that's
not helping the program or helping the
person so the Privacy is is kind of
overcoming more than it should yeah
there are certainly some barriers um
that the Privacy um creates however when
people are known to various doorways um
we are doing something called case
conferencing where sort of everybody
gets together to talk about a case that
might be really difficult in nature um
the other thing that often happens with
people who are active in their substance
use disorder and potentially unhoused is
that they're naturally moving throughout
the state so they're not intentionally
saying I'm going somewhere else in order
to access care and circumvent the system
they just are experiencing homelessness
in different parts of the state at
different times based on um where
they're able to find and maintain
housing I just wish we could change it
because supposedly the audit can take
place anywhere we've given public money
we should be able to audit and if these
things are are putting barriers in the
way they should be removed sure I think
we could look into the updates that 42
CFR part two had they're supposed to be
closer in line um with HIPPA um Medicaid
claims are often the easiest for the
Department to access where we can um
sort of at least pull our beneficiaries
of our insurance program and the doorway
program and line things up again it's
limited in nature but that's what we've
been successful to do in the past and
offer some protection from
privacy I was wondering we should have
access
to the um interactions of the Medicaid
recipients yeah certainly for billable
Services um I will venture to say
there's a lot of services that are being
provided by the doorways that are not
billable in nature but yes at least the
treatment
components so I have a couple of
questions this this program when it
started was called the Hub and spoke and
it was not a treatment program it was a
referral program and as I read this
scope statement it looks like there's
been Mission creep into treatment and
support and not just referrals but when
I look at table two on page five I
really don't see treatment or support
only in the lock Zone distribution
so I'm wondering
why the doorways say they Pro they're
providing treatment and support when
they were created to be a referral
program yeah sure great question um so
originally in 2018 when the state opioid
response Grant sort of first came to New
Hampshire came to every state in
jurisdiction um in the country we when
we heard from the community about what
the department should use this funding
for resoundingly the question that
needed to be answered was when people
are ready to get Services where do they
go and that the community was asking for
sort of a One-Stop shop place to send
folks and so it was created in this Hub
and spoke model over the over time as
the doorways have implemented our
service providers in the treatment space
were not always able to provide timely
access to treatment so there have been
two two things that have happened the
doorways sometimes provide like a bridge
where they would um provide therapy or
medications in the meantime while
someone gets connected to care or in
some cases they're just beginning to
receive their care from the doorways and
with the intent to stay um it is has
been in response to the community need
and to the building up of our substance
use disorder infastructure um but you
are correct that it is not just a
referral and um transfer sort of system
but that the doorways are providing
treatment and services on their own so
should table two be
expanded to include treatment and
support or
Recovery Services
clients because I really don't see that
there yeah those metrics are from the
monthly report um that the doorways
provide to the
department but that would be good
probably to
um I
also
wonder I've always wondered about the
weekdays from 8:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m. how
effective that is for meeting the
clients when they need the help I mean
this this program replace safe stations
in Manchester in Nashville where you
could walk into a firehouse 24 hours a
day and in Nashville at least a
treatment provider would show up within
15 minutes I think Manchester took a
little longer
but is it possible for this audit to
look
at how many more people could
be served if the inperson hours
were expanded and we backed away from
really most of the time being on a
phone and so that's another question I
have
also um I know that you that the
doorways will help
pay for someone's out of pocket cost for
methodone treatment
and is
that possible to look at how many people
how much I mean because we're spending
$2,000 a client sure so what are we
getting sure so in regards to the first
question I certainly think that when
people are accessing care day of the
week in time is something that could and
should be looked at
um anecdotally I know that about half of
the volume of the doorways is happening
outside of business hours right so
that's 5:00 p.m. to 8:00 a.m. weekends
and holidays um certainly in certain
regions more than others and so looking
at the times that people are accessing
care um and the volume that's
represented could be really important
because we are doing a lot over the
phone and it's not as effective um just
by the the limitations of being on the
phone with someone rather than in person
um and then secondarily there is the
funds that allow for for um methodone
treatment are a broader base fund that's
called the flexible needs fund um and my
my recommendation would be that that was
looked at broadly about what it um is
paid paying for um in addition to
medications so that group of funds can
also pay for housing and child care and
transportation um it's not a ongoing
source of funding and so the places that
it would be used to pay for someone's
medication would be um um shortterm and
temporary less than 30 days while their
insurance was established um but it's
designed to reduce Financial barriers to
care but it's most often for
transportation so if I use the same
scenario as before I present at the
doorway in Dober I'm screened clinically
for an evaluation and I require a
residential level of care that bed is
available in lonia and I can't
physically get there the doorway can pay
for your transportation from do to lonia
to make sure you get the care you need
in a timely fashion without having to
worry about the $200 cab ride that you
might need to pay
for are those S funds too yes so there
are no General funds that support this
program no there are at times Blended
Governor's commissions funds from the
alcohol fund but not General
funds okay so are you able to amend the
scope to address these
questions um we could
we could amend it
um we were planning on addressing some
of those issues anyway in the audit um
and I can just make a note of that and
we can probably move on without without
without making an amendment language yes
but uh it is something i' I've jotted
down some notes that we can we can
certainly uh address in the
audit okay any further
questions yes represented or
I I don't have a question but I have a
number of comments if that's
appropriate um at this point in time I
plan to propose this um essentially
there for a few reasons one you
essentially had an outside performance
audit performed last year as you
indicated by another firm and the
results of that are well reported on the
HHS
website it's also a federal program and
there's Federal reporting required and
there again the Department's done a
great job of making those monthly
reports available on their website along
with a really nice interactive dashboard
that you can also work with on a
countywide basis Statewide basis uh to
see the current results on a
month-to-month basis and
overall and it's all federal funds as
has been noted here and I think a
performance audit is better directed to
our general funds that's my personal um
feeling about this but the big problem I
have is here we are at the 11th Hour of
the term we literally end at midnight
tonight and in some ways we're jamming
up brand new legislature that's going to
be sworn in within the next 24 hours so
um I think this is a wrong time to be
approving uh the scope statement thank
you well based on representative Earth's
comment here I guess my question is do
we have to do this today or can we wait
and do this and let the newly seated
committee do this is is is there a re
excuse me is there a reason from your
perspective in the LBA that we need to
have this done
today um it's a hard question to answer
um I think the answer is uh no we don't
need uh it to be approved today um
however this commission uh this
committee
I guess expires tonight M um and we'll
we'll have a new committee uh with we
don't know who will be appointed to that
so it's
it's it's unknown at this point whether
the new committee would approve it or
not right which I I guess sort of leads
to the point of maybe it's better to let
the new committee direct you since
that's who you'll be working with them I
mean I suspect many of us will be back
here again but I I know there will be
some new faces here I ju Just my
thoughts I wasn't sure if there was a a
pressing reason why we had to do this
today well I just say we did approve
this performance audit months and months
ago so and it was it I think a unanimous
approval Senator yeah I was going to say
I think it's more appropriate for this
committee to improve the scope to
approve the scope one because we
approved the actual audit to proceed and
we requested that they produce the scope
statement in December and they did that
so I do feel like it's uh respectful of
their time and more appropriate for this
committee to vote on it okay
representative
Weber uh I would I would agree with that
and then the other thing I I just want
to say is that um whether it's federal
funds or whether it's state funds it is
a state program and it is
State uh citizens um and if we are are
spending $76 million effectively that's
great but if we are spending $76 million
ineffectively I think we ought to know
that and figure out how to do it better
uh so I think the fact that the source
of the funds is federal and that there
are certain federal oversights certainly
I I would hope you would just
incorporate what's already been done for
work and not start over and I assume
that part of the reason that this is a
fairly
shortterm uh relatively speaking um uh
audit reflects that but for me the issue
is whether we are making effective use
of resources for the benefit of citizens
of New Hampshire and that is doesn't
depend on where the funds come from and
I I would agree with that because we
have a limit on sore funds and we keep
expecting we're going to get less of
them and so I think it's important for
us to figure out if if this is a good
use of these federal funds or could we
be using them in a better way to provide
treatment and Recovery Support
Services to the thousands of granite
Staters who over from opioid use
disorder so I I think they on our do
have done what we've asked them to
do
um I know there will be a new committee
at some point I don't know when it'll be
appointed it'll be the house is turn to
share it I think isn't this one that
flips back and forth
um
so any further just yes gra thank you
madam chair um I'll just make one
comment related to your what you just
said I believe this is not just a
federal program but it's it's this
explicit program for all 50 states I
don't think we can take the $76 million
and decide to spend it in some other
more effective way in which case I think
you have a very good point but I think
we're basically stuck this is the
program that the federal government
wants us to run and this is the program
we have are requ to run Madam chair is I
don't think that's correct I don't think
that's correct
either so um what the uh substance abuse
in mental health administration dictates
is essentially a list of required
activities of which New Hampshire has
says this is how we're going to meet
these required
activities um so it's one of sort of a
list if it is found that things are
being run inefficiently we can every 12
months make adjustments to our budget um
so for instance we're in a current um
Federal funding year where the plan for
October needs to be presented to the
feds in February um so we're sort of
always on this 12-month um wheel with
them where we're adjusting one of the
main ways that we're adjusting as we go
with the doorways is that their
thirdparty billing has increased over
time quite significantly because of the
treatment component um that you brought
up before and so what you'll see is
money to the doorways decreasing over
time but that's because they're
leveraging other sources of funds as
well and so um I would encourage the
committee to look uh potentially across
funding sources and at like sort of the
bigger picture and not just at this um
use of temporary Grant dollars um but
the senator is right that the sore
allocation is temporary in nature and is
currently funding infrastructure which
um could be problematic for the citizens
if the funding went
away Madam chair I move acceptance of
the audit
scope is there second second
any further
discussion do we want to have a roll
call or can we have a show of
hands if you're in favor of accepting
the scope statement please raise your
hand one two three four five six
seven and one of post thank you very
much for your work
okay is there any suspended tabled and
potential audit
topics yes representative wer I've had a
couple of people talk to me about
turnovers being worse in some parts of
the state employees than others and I'm
wondering how best to address this
whether we would look at go through all
HR and see which places are having a
bigger turnover and and you know Zone in
on them or whether it's we should go to
the particular one I've had complaints
about any
thoughts well that came out of
nowhere yeah it's well this was this was
one thing that somebody said what are
you doing about it this agency has a big
turnover and and you know what's what
can we do about it I'm wondering if if
an audit would be a way to go ah
representative
Weber I think that it would be helpful
if we had specific programs because I
mean the entire state is pretty Broad
and I know for example in areas that I
deal with sometimes there is the
question question of turnover in say
various dcyf offices and there's a huge
differential between one set and another
but I think it would be really helpful
to hone in on
specific program areas rather
than just the whole ball of
wax would certainly sharpen my thinking
the point is if somebody says there's a
big turnover in our agency and we look
across the whole well there's a bigger
turnover over here and nobody's
complaining about it well there's a
bigger turnover in another one so if if
I take the one I've got complaints about
have him Zone in on that are we missing
some of the bigger problems
that's so are you suggesting an audit
of HR vacancies well yeah I mean if if
you went to HR and said give us the
turnover rate by agency
and then you could Zone in on say well
are these complaints I'm hearing more
valid in that agency than there is in
this agency so you know it it's just a a
matter of looking at like a a year or a
year and a half uh rate of turnovers
in in all the agencies in the
states I don't know how how wide that
would
be how many auditors
uh this is an interesting discussion um
interesting audit topic too that um I'm
sure we'd love to explore at some point
if it helps at all we're not looking for
a new topic
today we do still have um there are two
audits on the list that are currently
suspended as you know the um Bureau of
elderly and Adult Services and the aate
placements and then the last two audits
um on the list were uh DHHS audits so it
was contract management and then the
Bureau of Developmental Services those
are still on the list as potential audit
topics um and uh we still have Auditors
tied up on other audits right now so um
we can keep those on the list if you'd
like or uh we'd be happy to also
entertain additional topics if you'd
like and we can add them to the list
after uh these
too yes representative Weber given that
you're not looking for added work at the
moment I would suggest along the points
that were made earlier that those are
two that could wait for the
reconstituted committee so that they
could start a fresh with
fresh eyes and fresh
perspectives and that um we simp L leave
them for the moment because we don't
want to let go of them but uh that that
would be a good thing to have as a
starting point for the next committee
when you know when you have more
Auditors available uh always being aware
that we're going into a budget year so
anybody who is crossing the aisle so to
speak is going to be very busy indeed
you mean going from audit to budget
division um
okay so the next committee will consider
looking at
vacancies across state
government um other
business recognition of this isn't this
great do you all have this yep
so yay great audit of liquor enforcement
and Licensing this is wonderful that was
a very extensive audit it 300
Pages it was and it was a it was an
interesting and hard
read congratulations on this it's yeah
well done really well done thank you
very much well earned and please tell
whoever worked on it our congratul
ulations yes if I may just say a few
words um so as you know by looking at
your hand out there um it's a national
award um that uh one of our performance
audits received that had a significant
impact on public policy um it was for
the performance audit the 2021 audit of
the Liquor Commission the division of
enforcement and
Licensing um I'm proud of the work that
was done by the performance audit team
and and um Madame chair I'd like to
recognize them and thank them publicly
if that's okay yes please do the team
members included Andrea Provost Jonah
felstead Stephen Smith and uh two
Auditors who are in the room today um
Steve Grady is sitting in the back there
and uh Jay Henry performance audit
supervisor so um we're very proud of
them and I want to thank them for a job
well done and uh congratulations it was
well deserved and it
was very
impactful it was a great helpful audit
thank you I just going to mention Steve
Grady was the in charge of that audit
and the in charge position is always the
toughest hardest to do because you're
running the audit you're getting the
questions from management and for the
legislature this was the audit itself if
you remember in fiscal the same day we
had two
this size that we presented in front of
fiscal and uh one thing this this
awarded for impact meaning something
happened and a lot of legislation was
changed because of this and also rules
were written by the the um commission
and policy and procedures developed uh
based on what they reported back to
fiscal committee and to the um New
Hampshire transparency site so we were
basing their the impact on what the
commission has reported they've done um
so a lot goes to the commission and also
the legislature
for making sure impact
happened well I I mean that's the whole
reason to do these performance offs
right and I always look when we see them
is legislation required or not and um
they're really helpful
so thank you and
congratulations thank you madam chair
and I I think um given past practice uh
the chair will write a letter to fiscal
because we we get we present this to
fiscal too so the new fiscal committee
meeting so I there's a I have a letter
here for me yes there's one right here
for you the chair will write a letter
yes air quotes yeah all right
congratulations and and really thank you
and please tell those individual
Auditors who are not in the room how
proud we are at them thank you okay so
um we don't know when the next meeting
is going to be we don't know who will be
on the
committee
um I don't think there's any further
business before so yes just want to say
thank you mad chair for running a great
committee
this was not a huge lift did great this
committee I like to stay on it next time
it's would you like a motion to adjourn
um yes motion to
adjourn all in favor I I thank
you e